Was it my imagination?
Talk to me.
I have visions.
I write them down, and...
people pay to read them.
Scott had a history of
becoming unstuck...
to reality.
Where'd you go?
He called it being "gone".
I don't know how to do this
without you.
Come back.
I'm on a bool hunt.
What's a bool hunt?
Like a scavenger hunt,
Scott and his brother made up
when they were kids.
Mrs. Landon,
I just thought I'd give it
one more try in person.
Scott's unpublished works
need to be collected,
examined--
You are never
going to see his papers.
She won't let them go.
I'll get those papers for you.
Scott Landon's books changed me.
Do you remember that night
you asked if I was crazy?
I believed in it.
That's how strong
his imagination is.
There's a place.
I'll take you there.
What is this?
Where are we?
If you solve all the riddles,
find all the clues,
then you get a prize.
Where we went today,
was it real?
Or was it my imagination?
♪ I said Doctor ♪
♪ Mr. M.D. ♪
♪ Won't you tell me ♪
♪ What's wrong with me ♪
He's gone,
but he keeps pushing me.
Toward what?
Was it real?
Or was it my imagination?